Jimmy sells his catch at the local market. He
knows that he can sell only fresh fish, so he
throws the bad ones away, regardless of the time
it takes him to find, catch, and clean the fish.
Jimmy knows that if he were to sell spoiled goods,
his customers would not return. So, instead of
crying over stale fish, he considers them as sunk
costs and sells what customers actually want.
In his free time, Jimmy isn't’ that rational
Unlike fish that don't go to the movies, Jimmy
does. He buys himself a ticket for the afternoon
show. But it turns out that a few hours before
the film starts, his friends want to meet up to
play football, Jimmy's favorite sport. Since
he has already spent the money on the ticket,
he declines the invitation. According to sunk
costs theory, he shouldn’t have — the money
he spent on the tickets is already gone, and
he won’t get it back by watching the movie.
What matters is that he has a good time.
Jimmy falls for the so-called sunk cost
fallacy, the strong natural fear of losing
what we already own and the tendency of our
brain to treasure all the things we possess.
A more famous example of the fallacy is the
Concorde — the supersonic passenger plane.
Building the aircraft proved to be very difficult
and expensive, but instead of shutting down the
project, the British and French governments
continued funding it even though they knew the
aircraft would not have any economic benefit. They
argued that they had invested too much to give up.
To test the sunk cost fallacy, economists
Hal Arkes and Catherine Blumer came up with
an experiment using theater season tickets.
The regular price for the season was $15,
but some people were randomly given discounts of
either $7 or $2. It turned out that the people
who had paid the regular price attended more plays
than those who received a discount. Interestingly,
the only ones who behaved rationally
were children under the age of 6.
Behavioral economists suggest that there are
three psychological reasons for our irrationality.
1. Loss aversion: people prefer avoiding
losses to acquiring equivalent gains — most
avoid bets where they can win $50
because they could also lose $50.
2. The desire not to appear wasteful:
this is why some finish their food even
when they feel full or don’t
think it’s particularly tasty.
3. To ensure we do things we
fear we otherwise wouldn’t:
We might buy expensive gym membership to
make sure we actually go and work out.
Assuming you are immune to the Concorde
fallacy and you could completely ignore
all investments you have ever made into your
education or getting to where you are today:
What would you be doing differently
going forward? Can you identify any
'sunk costs' that are holding you
back from making those changes?
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com